for the toronto blue jays it'll be
left-hander
robbie ray the rays getting their second
look at
him he pitched against them back on
april the 24th the trump candidate field
went six innings gave up three earned
runs
randy rosa rayner steps in the box a
little looper in the center field
jonathan davis is there one up one down
now yandy diaz
serving as the designated hitter
and bo bobbles it a couple of times but
stays with it and makes a good play
brandon lau
lefty on lefty nice play by guriel in
his first chance of the ball game
good start for robbie ray three up three
down shane mcclanahan the rookie four
starts this year he won his first big
league game last saturday against the
mets he's got a big arm way to marcus
simeon what a pretty big day yesterday
swing and a miss
he struck him out got him on a slider
down in the way and simeon
is out number one here in the bottom of
the first one out here's little buchet
by the hand with the throw to first
stretch there by troy to help out and
buchette
is out number two two outs and there's
vlad guerrero jr who
had a couple of home runs in yesterday's
game outside he takes the ball
ball four so guerrero walks for the 29th
time i'm going to take my chances with
ty oscar hernandez
breaking ball drilled to right field and
it's over the head of margot
here comes guerrero he's being waved
around it's an rbi double by tay oscar
hernandez
and it's one nothing toronto here in the
first and randall grichik here's a
swinging grounder towards short
taylor walls has it his throw across
perfect and that will
retire the size manuel margot is going
to lead it off here in the
second inning there's a fly ball oscar
hernandez hits high enough so he has a
beat on it
and those low liners those are the balls
that have been giving the left fielder
trouble
i think off the bat he wasn't really
sure where it was but he had time to
locate it makes the pitch
here's mike brasso ground ball simeon
will come after it
takes an easy hop two up two down five
in a row retired by robbie ray to start
this game
so with two outs on the basis empty here
is jimon choi joy takes this one the
other way that's going to be in there
cut off by
hernandez joy's on his way to second
base and he's
in standing with the two base hit here
is mike cenino with an rbi chance the
rays were uh
a little less than stellar yesterday
with runners in scoring position 3-2
pits
popped up daddy janssen
has a beat on it right behind home plate
and he hangs with it makes the play what
is guriel
jr leads off not see him in yesterday's
game
well he's swinging the bat lately and
good to see him back in the lineup as he
rips that pitch past the diving
shortstop
blue jays get their lead off man aboard
now the hitter
and 99 with a fastball toward the right
field corner and margaux chasing it
makes the catch and the throw back
towards
second and guerrielle is going to be
doubled up
and for whatever reason guriel who was
about halfway then
after marco caught the ball he took off
for second base i'm not sure what he was
doing
i don't know what he was thinking right
there because the play was right in
front of him
well the first time through the race
with a double two out doubled in the
second by choi
here's a rose arena the ground ball to
the right side but two hits left off the
glove of marcus simeone on the right
field
should be an e4 it looked like he had
gotten to the baseball and then it
just rolled up his arm and should be an
e4 i would think
on marcus simeone that'll give gandhi
diaz an opportunity
there goes the runner the pitch up and
in and the throw will go into
center fielder rosarina will head to
third and he will be there
without a play stolen base for a rose
arena
one and two lined to simeon
and even though the jays commit two
errors and basically give the raise a
man at third
the race could not cash in robbie ray
pitching with a one-nothing lead
brandon lau grounded out to the first
baseman his first time
strikes out brendan wow first strikeout
for
ray tonight came right back with another
change-up and that's the second strike
out of the game to robbie ray three up
three down here comes mike cenino five
of his ten home runs against lefties
one-two pitch and this one's driven to
deep left field
hernandez turns around and we are
tied mike zanino with his 11th home run
of the season
and it's a 1-1 ball game here in the top
of the fifth
taylor walls making his major league
debut at the plate here's the swing in
the line drive toward right
back out of this bridgeick to the wall
and it's off the top of the wall
taylor walls with a double off the wall
in right field it's his first big league
hit
who's most excited the fans his
teammates are walls himself
two outs and we'll go back around to the
top of the order big batter
right here for mcclanahan and a cut in
the miss
he strikes out simeon on a good fit down
and in
stolen base number five for manuel
margot
right back up the middle but simeon was
positioned perfectly but also hit it
hard but that'll end the inning we now
get a chance to see the newest raid jp
fire rising over from the milwaukee
brewers last pitch on wednesday
ground ball short stop out there and
walls throw to first
out there robbie ray has been terrific
he has given up a solo home run and
nothing more
breaking ball and troy strikes on second
time he's gone down
swinging another choo-choo pitch called
strike three boy what a pits by robbie
ray
bury that fastball right on the inside
corner
doing two
[Applause]
there here comes t oscar he'll get there
how about robbie ray
and they're gonna not pitch to allow
they're gonna intentionally walk him
set up margot
do up he pitches breaking ball good take
that time blown into the dirt trying for
throws arena and the throw
not in time randy takes third
on the ground and through the left side
for a base hit the raise
take a two-to-one lead runners set it
first and second now with two gone
and here's the oscar hernandez and uh
swing and miss
he got him wall's on his way to second
and he's gonna stand there
with his second double in his big league
debut and a double right-handed now
double left-handed
and now walls is gonna go to third and
the throw gets away he's gonna score
and the rays will pick up that extra
round three to one raise as taylor walls
making things happen
on the bases gives the rays a little
insurance
so the blue jays are down to their final
out and it's rhys mcgloiner
swinging a high fly ball to center this
should do it margot getting underneath
it and he makes the catch in the rays
have won nine in a row